quick way back in the freezer family
there was actually a phrase my grandma
said to me which is you know my grandma
who was you know a king Gardener nor
recruiter I would remember like
in a little floral chair floral carpet
and she would say it's all pass and I
think that is so true in life and life
you get so anxious about things you
experience things like imposter syndrome
it's really really tough and recruitment
is one of those careers it's why we talk
about it you know in the way that we are
if it's one deal that's a drop in the
ocean if you're looking at your week
it's one thing to happen your week if
you look in your month your quarter your
year is a drop in the ocean